[Music]
the big bang theory is one of the most
popular sitcoms of all time but the show
isn't perfect over the course of nearly
300 episodes writers sometimes forgot
plot points and actors occasionally lost
touch with their characters here are the
goofs that are hardest to overlook
sheldon cooper is a creature of habit
perhaps because he is a scientist
striving to find meaning and order in a
chaotic universe he exerts control over
nearly every part of his life this
manifests in his strict dinner schedule
and his spot it's well understood among
his social circle that no one is to sit
on the far right end of the brown couch
in the apartment's living room except
sheldon hello penny hello sheldon you're
in my spot he has called that
comfortable and familiar spot a quote
single point of consistency in a world
in flux upon which he has placed eternal
dibs in part because it has a good angle
of the tv and never gets too hot or too
cold on the prequel show young sheldon
young sheldon has a similar spot of
preference in his school cafeteria
nevertheless the big bang theory's
directors sometimes forgot about this
major element of sheldon's character and
allow other people to sit in the
hollowed spot even while sheldon is in
the room it's weird that someone so
adamant about his seat on the couch
doesn't notice or mind when howard or
leonard occupies it but hey that's tv
for you
sheldon cooper's strict approach to the
calendar applies to everything from meal
planning to his leisure activities early
in the show it's established that
sheldon and the guys have a weekly
standing date to play the video game
halo every wednesday night penny hits
sheldon and leonard's apartment during
one session and mentions that christy
her friend from back home in nebraska
showed up uninvited and is staying at
her apartment upon hearing that christy
is promiscuous howard flees the game and
goes across the hall to proposition her
and the two wind up using penny's
bedroom to hook up well um howard and
christy are
kind of hooking up in my bedroom penny
with nowhere to sleep that night crashes
on the couch in sheldon and leonard's
place that's all well and good until the
next morning when a robe-clad sheldon is
mad that a sleeping penny has
interrupted his saturday morning
tradition of watching doctor who either
the big bang theory writers goofed up
and forgot that the previous evening was
wednesday or penny slept continuously
from halo night to saturday morning
roommate disputes are voluminous and
varied on the big bang theory especially
between precise sheldon and exasperated
leonard as a preemptive measure and to
make sure his home life strictly adheres
to his tastes in every way sheldon draws
up a lengthy and elaborate roommate
agreement its existence is referred to
often as are its comically numerous
articles writers and clauses one aspect
of the agreement a girlfriend clause is
especially ridiculous per sheldon's
legalese any relevant woman is
considered to be cohabiting with leonard
and sheldon and is subject to all the
rules and costs of such if she stays
over for ten straight nights more than
nine total nights over three weeks plus
all the weekends of a month plus three
weekdays even though this roommate
agreement gets brought up throughout the
big bang theory leonard violates the
girlfriend clause with regularity and
there's little to no fallout all of
leonard's female romantic partners stay
over and stay over often including
stephanie priya and penny with little
incident for the first few seasons of
the big bang theory sheldon cooper loves
cats but in a strictly theoretical sense
as he's allergic several times sheldon
insists that penny sing his favorite
childhood song in order to soothe and
relax him in times of physical or
emotional duress soft kitty which is
about how a kitty is soft warm covered
in fur happy sleepy and likes to purr in
the fuzzy boots corollary the third
episode of the entire show leonard
considers compensating for the lack of a
romantic relationship in his life by
getting a cat assuring an extremely
worried sheldon that the latter's
medical sensitivities won't come into
play because he's going to buy a
genetically modified hypoallergenic cat
oh i hope that scratching post is for
you but three years later in the fourth
season episode the zazzy substitution
it's sheldon who gets a cat to deal with
the loneliness he's enduring after
breaking off his romance with amy farrah
fowler worried that the first cat named
dr j robert oppenheimer after the famous
scientist is lonely sheldon adopts more
cats all of them named after great men
of science all except for zazzles who is
a decidedly zazzy little fellow bringing
home so many cats is a sign of an
emotional breakdown for sheldon but it
doesn't trigger a physical one he
doesn't exhibit a single symptom of his
previously explained cat allergy now if
you'll excuse me the father of the
atomic bomb wants a saucer of milk
while howard wallowitz is often mocked
by sheldon cooper for not having a phd
he holds a mere master's degree in
aerospace engineering from mit he
achieves something that no other
character on the show does he goes to
space in a plot are expanding seasons 5
and 6 of the show howard is selected to
travel to the international space
station alongside two other astronauts
heading to space has its ups and downs
for the goofy howard but it's ultimately
a rewarding experience he appreciates
which is good because in real life
someone like him would likely never make
it to the iss in a real-life space
training program he would have been
weeded out and disqualified in any
number of ways such as when he has
trouble navigating nasa's flight
preparation system they do it over and
over again no matter how many times you
throw up neither would he pass the
physical what with his genetic
predisposition to heart problems and
severe asthma both putting him out of
the running
sitcoms are decidedly unrealistic and
the big bang theory is no exception it
seems unlikely that a bunch of
thoughtful intelligent people with
active social lives would hang around
someone as mean controlling and
judgmental as sheldon cooper for more
than a dozen years but it's downright
illogical that someone like penny would
live next door to sheldon and leonard in
the first place seriously the entire
premise of the show guy falls in love
with attractive neighbor is built on an
economic fallacy when the show begins in
2007 sheldon and leonard have been
roommates for years both contributing to
the rent on their spacious pasadena
apartment with the salaries they earn as
doctorate holding high-level scientific
researchers at the prestigious
california institute of technology
according to forbes each character would
be pulling in at least 100 000 a year
more than enough to afford half of an
apartment in expensive pasadena and yet
penny moves into the same building right
across the hall granted her digs
featured just one bedroom so it would
cost a little less than the guys pad but
it doesn't seem possible that she'd be
able to afford similar accommodations as
two well-compensated scientists on the
stingy salary of a cheesecake factory
waitress
sheldon cooper isn't like most people a
super genius who attended high school as
a little boy and graduated college by
the time he was 14 he's always had a
hard time relating to people his own age
moreover he operates from such a
staunchly logical and scientific mindset
that he fails to grasp emotionally
driven behaviors or subtle nuances and
conversations particularly sarcasm when
he senses that someone is being
sarcastic he has to receive confirmation
of it leonard even resorts to holding up
a sign that reads sarcasm when its use
is appropriate what's funny
dude that wasn't sarcasm despite
sheldon's complex relationship with
sarcasm however he's still a character
in a broad sitcom and sitcom characters
are the most naturally sarcastic people
in all of fiction within that segment
sheldon cooper is arguably one of the
most acerbic sneering and yes sarcastic
individuals to ever grace a tv screen he
doesn't understand sarcasm apparently
but he employs it all the time this one
is such a glaring discrepancy that it's
really just better to let it go entirely
you know how you're always trying to
learn about sarcasm no
no
i was being sarcastic
while all four male main characters and
their partners on the big bang theory
gather most nights for takeout dinner at
the big apartment the guys all work
together at the california institute of
technology and as such also get together
seemingly every work day for lunch in
the school's cafeteria this means
there's a lot of eating on the show and
pretending to consume food on stage or
screen is an acting challenge unto
itself the performers don't actually eat
the various sandwiches and salads on
offer in the caltech lunch room instead
the actors just move their forks and
knives around to mimic the process of
dining without placing the prop food
into their mouths they're remarkably bad
at pulling this off convincingly and
once you see it it's hard to mess
there exists a small pantheon of heard
but not seen characters from across tv
history and howard's mother mrs
wallowitz is a prime example and what
amounts to a running gag the show
strongly establishes that mrs wallowitz
is morbidly obese so large in fact that
no actress could play her but every so
often an episode gives viewers more of
mrs wallowitz than just her screaming at
her son in an exaggerated new jersey
accent and it always conflicts with her
allegedly huge size at one point she
wraps her arms around raj and while
they're the only part of mrs wallowitz
on camera they are the limbs of an
average-sized woman where you going
when howard marries bernadette in a
rooftop ceremony before he goes into
space the mother of the groom is seen in
an overhead shot of the affair standing
off to the side in a pink dress mrs
wallowitz doesn't seem to be all that
heavy set
perhaps it's because an occasional but
major role on the most popular sitcom on
tv pays well perhaps it's because
celebrity stunt casting is fun for a
show's cast crew and fans whatever the
reason the big bang theory had lots of
fun casting well-known performers to
play the parents of its regular
characters the good wife and the good
fight star christine baranski appeared
on the big bang theory 16 times as
leonard's mother beverly hofstadter a
world-renowned psychiatrist and
neuroscientist the first time she shows
up in the 2009 episode the maternal
capacitance she analyzes penny and helps
her work through her parental issues at
one point penny tells beverly about her
childhood referring to her father as bob
i mean my mom could have just said
get over it she's a girl a year and a
half later oscar winner keith carradine
made his first of five appearance on the
big bang theory is penny's stern
protective father but he introduces
himself not as bob but as wyatt thanks
for the steak wyatt penny's father
apparently has two first names
regardless like penny his last name is
never revealed
the big bang theory is a show about
scientists but not so much a show about
science while it's understood that most
of the main characters work to unlock
the secrets of the universe in some way
or another the show doesn't bog itself
down with anything more than the
occasional mention of a famous scientist
as a result the big bang theory rarely
shows the guys doing any real science
work when they conduct experiments
they're fun things that make for good
television despite being completely and
woefully scientifically inaccurate in
the vengeance formulation co-worker
barry kripke pranks sheldon before an
npr interview by pumping his office full
of helium the intended effect sheldon's
voice goes hilariously high-pitched as i
was saying an ordinary magnet has two
poles the real-life effect sheldon would
have suffocated to death with so much
helium replacing life-giving oxygen as
for leonard one of his job perks is
getting to use a giant laser for science
stuff a real university's laser would
have numerous safety protocols in place
such as the device not functioning if
the door to the laser room was open and
yet when leonard uses his laser he
carelessly leaves the door ajar and he
wears no safety equipment while
operating the laser
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one